Right?
Yeah,
there's a void there.
They need to fill some people addicted to eating.
Those are the same addiction essentially,
but one is a lot better to have than the other.
You know,
it's like even with,
I mean there's even with Kanye,
right?
Like I see Kanye as like this guy who's just wildly insecure and he's trying to
justify his coolness constantly by taking things that are not cool at all and
making them cool within a community,
within his community.
Right?
So it's like everything Kanye does like down to like,
it started with like the wasp culture.
I'm going to take like preppy New England,
you know,
polos that are pink and shit and I'm going to make that cool now before the hip
hop community.
I mean,
I grew up in New York,
we were like,
Yo,
that's some gay shit bro.
What the fuck is that now?
Kanya where's it's like,
Nah,
you gotta look fly in this,
these pink waspy things in my Khakis,
whatever.
Then he takes grunge culture,
right?
There's fuck,
have you seen the bright that's ripped sweaters and all that kind of shit?
That's Seattle Nirvana.
Shit.
But he's like,
Yo,
I bet I'm so cool.
I could make it cool.
Right?
They takes dad sneakers.
I'm so cool.
I could you take my community loves cool sneakers.
I'm gonna make dad sneakers.
Cool.
And then what is the most uncool thing to his community?
What Trump
and what does he try to make?
Cool.
It's selfish is all about him.
Oh,
he cares is about proving that he's that dude and he takes the most uncool thing
and puts it on his head and he's like,
Yo,
I'm going to make Magda cool.
And that's when people are like,
at least his community was like,
Nah,
we're not going to,
we're not going to play it.
Play with
that shit.
You know what I think?
I think,
uh,
you know how like you have something that's supposed to take like eight volts.
You have like a charger.
Yeah.
It's supposed to take,
like when you go to Europe and you plugged your shit,
right.
Well like when you plug something into the wall,
like we have alternating current,
like you could have something that takes way more amperage.
I think Kanye has the wrong plug to the universe and in a,
in a good way with that mother fuckers getting like a hundred volts all the
time.
So he wants to deal,
he ever talk to him?
No.
I talked to him on the phone and it was a stream of consciousness that was so
intense.
I was like,
okay,
now I get it.
I kind of go,
we had a long conversation.
He's a very nice guy.
We had a long conversation for like 1520 minutes on the phone,
which is a long conversation these days on the phone.
Yeah.
Blew the fuck.
Talks to the phone anymore.
He does.
Yeah.
But you're at your thing.
He's getting a hundred volts bro.
He's got design going through his head and new song lyrics and new fashion and
all this.
And I think he's just catching whatever he can.
Yeah.
And holding onto it and waiting through the waves to fill them.
But I don't know to fill,
there's a little bit of that.
But uh,
with him it's almost like affirming that he's okay because he's so much
different than everybody else.
Like Elon Musk,
like a lot of other people.
Sure.
Pete,
what's up?
Did,
uh,
when he used the confederate flag,
do you know about his statements on that?
He,
he said that like,
he,
he used this in a quote,
what does he say?
Oh,
react how you want any energy's good energy.
The confederate flag represents slavery in a way.
That's my abstract take on what I know about it.
Right?
So I wrote the song new slaves,
so we the confederate flag and made it my flag.
It's my flag.
Now what are you going to do?
Not what are you going to do?
It's how can I take my equity and see if I'm so dope?
But that's also his recognition that you can take something like the n word and
use it as a positive.
You could do anything.
I mean,
look,
if,
if black people really decide,
I used to do this bit,
okay,
go.
I used to as bit about,
uh,
to remember when the fucking duck dynasty guy was,
he was talking a lot of shit about gay people was like,
I don't understand it.
I don't understand.
And I was like,
look,
I don't understand yellow cars.
Shit.
If you understand why you wasting all your time.
Yeah,
you better be nice because I go,
if you keep fucking with gay people,
they're going to do something and they're going to do something and you're not
gonna be able to take it back.
Like what if gay people decided to take over Cammo and the bit was like,
look what they did to the rainbow.
I go own the rainbow.
I go,
you can't wear a rainbow shirt anymore.
Everybody like bath.
He used to be leprechauns and pots of gold.
Now it's dude's,
but fucking would have to do is start off every gay porn in a duck blind two
dudes cammo dynasty and you get the gayest black guy in the world in camels like
some about duck hunting,
make me holidays and some dude just drops in out of nowhere.
I'm pulls his camel down to the sucking his dick.
If they just had all porno in camera,
it would turn Cam.
I went to a gay thing and if black people just just went whole hog on the
confederate flag,
look at them.
They got Cammo wallpapers son.
Absolutely.
That's like some Andy Liba.
Which shit though?
That's like some vanity fair cover nonsense.
You know,
that's like some organized shoot.
Very Metta.
Those are weird.
Or what they're doing now.
These guys are smart.
They are,
by the way,
that's a shit pattern.
That's a bad cammo pattern.
All ducks ducks.
Maybe it's,
there's,
it might be their pattern.
So I bet it is a swamp.
It's like,
I dunno,
the gay shit is like,
you know,
it's just,
it's not the climate for it.
And I feel you.
Oh,
it could be.
Don't you mean remember deliverance,
but it's really like a pig.
Yeah,
but that was,
that was rape.
Yay.
That was Cambridge.
Everybody says it's not sex.
It's about power.
Well then they didn't do it right,
but they also didn't get raped.
Let's get a fuck you,
I mean,
powers of part of it for sure,
but they're just going to fuck you man.
Fuck.
Like this ain't sex,
bro.
Just so we're clear,
That guy is fucking you.
This is about sex and power.
I get it.
You're not gay,
but it's still suck.
People want it,
man.
That's the thing.
I don't know.
I think the Kanye thing like he's just a guy who thinks way different.
Like for whatever reasons,
the connections.
That's one of the reasons why I think this Kim Dash in relationship works so
well is cause like I bet she just handles normal regular stuff and he could just
be Kanye.
You know what I mean?
Like it seems like they've,
does he think people how different death defense
tell me.
Convince me because the music is phenomenal outside of that.
Okay.
It's real simple.
Yeah.
Have you ever been locked up in a mental institute?
No.
He has.
Yeah.
They don't just lock you up bro.
They never locked me up.
You know my wife Never,
I never came home.
My wife has some fucking two gorillas that are in those,
a lab suits that are staring at me.
I'm like,
what's with the big guys?
Big Guys are going to take it to a nice hospital.
Like sure,
we'd like to handle this quietly.
What the fuck.
I'm not going with some hospital.
I can't spell good leg kicks Gel.
You don't just go to the mentalist too,
bro.
They fucking,
they velcro.
You put the mental tissue doesn't mean that you are genius.
There's a lot of crazy people who are just crazy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well he's definitely crazy.
Sure.
But he's also,
but he's brilliant to see the work that comes out of that crazy is genius work.
Right.
So what is it about him that allows him to be so prolific as an artist here?
Notice how prolific is.
Yeah,
so you guys constantly,
constantly banging out songs,
Khan and there,
there's,
he doesn't have bad albums.
No,
he's,
he is phenomenal at music without a doubt.
Phenomenal at music.
But this is all from this energy that's inside of him.
He figures out how to channel that energy and put it in good ways,
but occasionally,
like it's not awesome.
It's easy.
It's not a coincidence.
It's not a coincidence that when Kanye was on stage,
I think it was in San Jose and he said that he didn't vote,
but if it was going to vote,
he would have voted for Trump.
And the crowd went crazy and they booed the shit out of him.
And then he canceled his tour and then he went to demand mental health
institute.
All that shit happened together because he felt the pain of this.
Then his response to that was to double down.
His response to that was to attribute qualities to Trump that he doesn't even
really have.
Right.
And so Trump in his,
in a lot of ways,
very wise,
the way he handles things socially,
he let Kanye coming to the White House where that maggot hat and just ramped up
a storm.
So Kanye could define who Trump was.
He could defy what loving Trump meant.
Should we get defined why black people should,
should embrace Trump.
He could define all this in his head to sort of justify what went wrong with
him.
Right?
And then Trump just sits there and goes like this and let them talk.
And then he leaves.
The Trump goes,
what the fuck?
Phone call or it's a pizza Dick.
Suck
this shit right here.
That's it.
This is now look at that white lady with her arms crossed in the background.
Like what in the fuck I need to know like what the fuck am I watching?
The blonde chick right there in the center.
Look at her face.
She's like,
okay,
what that's her face says,
what Kanye is like showing Donald Trump his phone and cut Donald Trump's get his
lips,
purse,
phone.
Amazing.
Cushner show me some lyrics.
Devious smile.
Coasters face dude.
Dude.
How about the black dudes sitting there like,
I can't believe I have
just
face.
He's like,
what in the fuck do I do when I get fired from here?
Cause I know it's coming.
I know it's government
about the dude in the back of the beard who get the brother in the back.
He's like,
man,
fuck it up.
You gotta be fucking Shit.
Me Ryan Gosling with the boom mic.
Oh look at that guy.
Yes,
Magda all the way.
He's like,
I can't wait to get on Gab and talk about this amazing meeting of the minds to
look at his face.
Has who Trump reached out to,
you know,
I'm friends with his son though.
Like text friends.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a nice guy.
He's a hunter.
We know each other through mutual friends and one of our mutual friends who
committed suicide.
Oh Shit.
So I was like,
no,
but,
uh,
he's a nice guy.
I mean,
I don't agree with a lot of things that,
a lot of people that I know agree with.
Yeah.
I think,
I think we're allowed to be reasonable and cordial with each other.
Yes.
What's the matter?
What are you laughing at?
What is Jim Brown was also sitting at that luncheon.